i was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says megan fox is
not shy about her passion for fiance
machine gun kelly which the pair
apparently expressed with blood drinking
ceremonies yeah like vampires i think
it's wonderful the 35 year old actress
makes the confession in glamour uk's new
digital issue she says she and mgk have
different approaches to the ritual quote
when i do it it's a passage or it is
used for a reason it is controlled where
it's like let's shed a few drops of
blood and each drink it as for the
rocker megan says he is quote much more
haphazard and hectic and chaotic where
he's willing to just cut his chest open
with broken glass and be like take my
soul i haven't done anything like that
this isn't the first time the couple's
been open about using blood to celebrate
their love
when the two got engaged earlier this
year megan shared on instagram that the
proposal ended only after we drank each
other's blood you have to be selfless
you have to always prioritize loving the
other person where they are as they are
who they are in this moment as for if
blood will come into play on the pair's
wedding day that's tbd but at the time
of their engagement a source told et
that megan and mgk are over the moon and
more in love with each other than ever
before quote they know that they are
each other's soul mates so they want to
get married sooner than later he is he's
so charismatic for a tall blonde
gorgeous
supermodel there's no wedding date yet
but our source tells us they want
something very dark yet romantic that
shows off their lux and sexy sides yeah
i love it it's amazing now the blood
reveal isn't the only confession megan
makes in glamour she also shares that
she's completely sober quote i don't
even drink a glass of wine i don't ever
smoke i don't drink coffee it's not
really that hard to balance she also
gets candid about her kids apparently
move to tears while discussing her
parenting approach especially when it
comes to letting them explore gender
identity i feel that it's my job as a
mother to to be their support system and
to offer them love and to help them
discover who they are but without
projecting my own
ideas or my own hopes or my own failures
onto them and so that means i have to be
comfortable with whatever they reveal to
me
and i i that's just what resonates and
makes sense to me i wouldn't know how to
parent any other way megan's opened up
in the past about her child noah's
desire to wear dresses telling the mag
she bought a bunch of books that explore
the topic
some of the books are just about how you
can be a boy and wear a dress you can
express yourself through your clothing
however you want i was raised in the
south where there were a lot of rules
and a lot of restrictions and i was told
exactly who i was supposed to be and
judged very harshly and critically
and
that's just not something that i want
from my kids i don't want that for my
little boy the transformer star says
ever since her kids were young she's
made discussions about topics like
gender identity are part of their
everyday lives but that doesn't stop the
mom of three from worrying about her
kids quote i just wish that humanity was
not like this although my kid is so
brave and i know that they've chosen
this journey for a reason it's just hard
as a mom